[Music]
as is no way he means to doubts
[Music]
I love the way that was given love
[Music]
in fact every time you step into the a
they standing [ __ ] cheers Amaya
he always said a stand
somehow we want to be is just bring back
so many memories
the way / doubtful mouth in the crazy
time the gods
the shine
in statue one day
burgle is was the only Bangkok that was
a stretch for gather led his team to a
championship it's around on the throws
it down
at the beginning I didn't know what to
expect I came here as a 20 year old kid
right our German didn't play college
with the ninth pick in 1998 I was
nervous I was nervous where this is
going to go my first year and there were
times were struggling to play much I had
a lot of doubts in my head but I found
the people
amazingly nice to me I don't know why
maybe
wanted me to succeed mother though most
people have been nice to me
you know it is you have to do some stuff
right you sit down so to get better
Dallas grew in my heart he was blessed
to have the discipline to work hard
definitely for me when the toughest guys
I ever had to check in his game off
physically
that is alleged to me because of he's
one of a kind you know I mean he's truly
one of a kind
[Music]
right back here
when you come in in this league water
establish yourself and
you know all-star games and all these
little things are nice and scoring but
what gives you to a certain age you're
basically seen at all and all you play
for us is this what I bring for the
Masters
I went through a lot of disappointments
with me over
the years
you know if you're in this league for 13
years and playoffs last basically 10
years 11 years and always come below
come up a little short so many times to
be rubber a good team of everybody
playing well if we're attacking from all
angles I think we're tough to beat
that's that's how we've been running all
season long
we got changed on pick for MVP of the
playoff right now Dorothy Adam you are
definitely the infancy of this playoff
Wow I mean the guy is just unbelievable
I just tried to take the challenge as
winter time it was the first game and we
play well as a team
Dallas had no opportunity to win this
game they should not have been in this
game the Mavericks work they didn't show
up and then all of a sudden for the Dirk
Nowitzki and that's what greatness gives
you when this guy was sensational
having seasons in NBA history
everything was new to me you know I
didn't know anything really about Dallas
and when you came in the league I don't
know if his ceiling was that high was
expectations nothing in life is going to
be given to you nothing is gonna come
easy and you have to work for it tonight
is about going into the city of Dallas
Hall of Fame you have given this city so
much you've been a great citizen of
Dallas you have given back to this city
of
you have representatives from all over
the world
by the big skeet textbook turn
we are going to
for the city
fade away with the knee up where's guys
now are copying him
with the fadeaway so that he just so
happened to be one of the best 16 611
game has ever seen
it's been an absolute honor represent
this franchise this great city and all
these great people all around the world
anytime just fly by if we have a funnel